it's very interesting what's happening
over there right right it's just gotten
very messy and very sloppy Gail King
weighs in on the TJ homes Amy robach
drama calling the whole thing messy and
sloppy you are responsible for those
decisions the CBS morning's co-host
dropped her two cents on Thursday's
episode of Watch What Happens live after
Andy Cohen asked her what she thought
about all the drama going down at Good
Morning America when all hell is
breaking loose at GMA or the Today Show
do you come into work and you open the
paper and like thank God it's not us no
it's just gotten very messy and very
sloppy yes I do think that Gail gave ABC
and GMA exec's props for their initial
stance of letting two consenting adults
remain on the air but the network
quickly changed its tune ads took the
GMA 3 co-hosts off the morning Show's
third hour they've been M.I.A for days
Amy Roebuck and TJ Holmes have the day
off a source previously told ET that
Kimberly Godwin the president of ABC
News addressed the situation during a
morning editorial meeting on Monday
saying that the relationship has become
an internal and external distraction and
for now Stephanie Ramos and Gio Benitez
will be filling in we are so glad you
are here with us to begin this brand new
week here on gma3 now multiple sources
tell ET that ABC is conducting a review
to see if Amy and TJ violated any
company policies and the investigation
will also look into TJ's alleged
relationships with other ABC employees
E.T previously learned that TJ also had
an affair with a producer who left the
morning show in 2017 and A source told
ET that he had an affair with a third
woman who is no longer at the network
the more you read it's just very messy
and I think it's just a to me a sad
situation because you've got kids
involved you've got families involved
and I keep thinking about that yeah I'm
very concerned about that of course this
all comes after Amy and TJ's secret
romance was made public Andrew and I are
in our second marriage we have a blended
family we have step children Ex-Wives
ex-husbands Amy is married to Melrose
Place Alum Andrew shoe yeah I'm doing
all right
considering everybody thinks I should be
falling apart and TJ has been married to
Marilee fibig an attorney who's also
chief of staff at Jay-Z's Rock Nation
for 12 years they share a daughter and
TJ's also dad to two other kids from a
previous relationship keeping the
romance alive in any relationship well
maybe it's the challenge these days just
a little bit sometimes Azores previously
told E.T the journalists both separated
from their spouses back in August and
while they haven't officially commented
on the Scandal they were quick to delete
their Instagram accounts after picks
went viral of them packing on the PDA
all over New York it's just very messy
meanwhile Don Lemon who used to work
with TJ at CNN is supporting his former
colleague well I'll say this I know TJ I
worked with TJ at um at CNN so I have
nothing but love for him and I hope that
he's okay I just like to offer people
love and support and I hope that they're
okay and I hope that they continue to
prosper as for TJ and Amy a source tells
ET the two are keeping a low profile and
letting the dust settle adding that they
are definitely together right now
[Music]